は：こんにちは！
は：はじめしゃちょーと
さ：こんにちは！佐々木あさひです！
は：はい！と言う訳で今回は、あさひさんが来てくださいました！
は：ありがとうございます
さ：いぇーい！（拍手）
は：これですね(Vサイン)
さ：そうですね(Vサイン)
は：と言う訳で、あさひさん。留学お帰りなさいませ（お辞儀）
さ：あ、ありがとうございます（お辞儀）
さ：ただいま
は：どうでしたか、海外は
は：寂しかったですか？
は：英語とかって学べました？
さ：学べた！だって、そのつもりで行ったから…
は：あ、ほんとですか
は：いやあ、ちょっと久しぶりにあさひさんと。えっと留学から
は：お帰りになって、日本で今
エンジョイしてるんですか？
さ：エンジョイしてます、エンジョイしてます！
というわけであさひさんが来てくださっているので　今回はちょっと
あさひさんとなにかしようと思います
あ；いぇーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーい！
メイク。
さ；おふうーお
は；おふうーお
で僕といえば
ま、・・・・・メイク。
メイクでやっぱこう共通の
は；ｒｊｇｈｇｋｌｄｊｇｂｋｌｆ
怒られないかちょっと
共通のカテゴリーがあるので
僕を女装させてください！
女装がしたいんだよね
女装がしたいです
じゃあ、女装してあげよう
ありがとうございます！
僕、一回動画でやったことがあるんですけども
ちょっとまた あさひさんがやる事によって
また違う女装の、違う女性観になるのかと思うので
え、自分でメイクしてんのもあったじゃん！
あれ、メイクって言えません
なんか塗りたくって
美意識はあるんですよ、少なからず男として
あさひさんに今回、美意識を
高めていただきたい
というわけで、本日はよろしくお願いします
よろしくお願いします
まずは、これつけて、ちょっと女の子の気持ちを
あ、これですか
ヘアバンド
全てを
だ、大丈夫ですか？
あ、カワイイ！
これですか、あ、よく観る。あさひさんと
すごい、すごい、すごい
あさひさんのアレですね
私が使っているやつ
バケモンじゃないですか！
カラコンつけれる？
え、怖いよ、大丈夫ですか？
わかんない！
つけれるんだったら、つけたい、可愛いかなと思って
じゃ、試してみましょう
試してみる？
目を大きく開けて
開けて、いくよぉぉ！
あぁあああ、こわぁああい！！
見ないで！
白目になって、白めに、そうそう
そうそうそうそう、見て、見ないで、見ないで
見ないでぇ、見ないでぇ…あぁ！
きゃあ、怖い！　眼球触れたｗｗｗ
ファンデーション、塗っていきます！
白いよね
本来、ぼく白いんですよ
しろ！
シュッとなった眉毛ね
めっちゃ言われるんですよ、それ
でもメイクやられ慣れているでしょ
大変塗りましたねぇ
メイクされる機会がふえたんですけどぉ
洗顔をメイク落とす時に、面倒くさいから
化粧落とし用の洗顔の
化粧落とし洗顔
一緒になっているやつ
あれ、お風呂場に置いているだけで彼女いる曰くがわくんですよ
はじめ、ぜってい彼女いんじゃんみたいな
アイシャドー行きたいと思います
そっち、そっち、ちょー塗りやすい！
よかった
うえ↑
それは上手
かわいい、カワイイ、可愛い
カッコイイですか？
そうそうそうそう、ぬりやす～
顔を小顔に魅せたいの
きっと下と上をけずれば、ちいちゃくなるかな～と思って
なるほど、なるほど！
ハイライト、明るさをだしてみまぁす
なるほどぉ
あきらかに、近づいてきています
近づいてきている？
あぁ、ちょちょちょ！
はい、こっち向いて
完璧ですか？　完璧！
のばす感じに、はぁ！
半口にして
上げていきます　はい
いい感じ
せーの
じゃじゃん
うぉおお↑↑↑！！
可愛くなーい？
すごい、なんか…
全然タイプが違う、まえと
なるほど、なるほど
これは、あれだな
セクシー系ですね
そう！
かわいい！
その角度！
ここ隠すと可愛く見れる気がする
できるできる！
うわぁ、スゴスギ！ありがとうございます！
やったー！
ただ…ガタイが問題ですね
今回のポイントは
この前と逆を出して
キレイ目にセクシーな感じに
しあげて、赤の衣装、ご用意いたしました
あ、あ、イイ！
あさひさんとボクの撮った動画が、もう一本あるので
下の概要欄にですね、
下の方で観れますので、ぜひ観てください！
見てくださいっ
というわけで、あさひさんとのコラボでした
ありがとうございました！
ありがとうございましたぁ！